host of a e's what's it worth uh one of
the
uh funniest comedians out there um for
many many years enjoyed this man's work
and of course
are you smarter than a fifth grader was
so popular for such a long time
um he is none other than jeff foxworthy
here on the rich eisen show how are you
jeff
i'm doing great brother how are you it's
been a long time i think since we
we we've chatted what's uh how's life
everything good for you
everything's good i mean it's different
it's uh
you know i've been doing stand-up for 36
years and i don't think i ever went
a week without being on stage and now
i've been on stage since
february all right that's up that's an
adjustment but
uh yeah everybody's healthy what was
your first gig
jeff well
my first i i worked at ibm
uh before i was a comic and i was the
guy in the break room
doing impersonations of the boss you
know that
you know that guy at every office and uh
a bunch of guys i work with um
entered me in a comedy contest not an
amateur night a contest for comedians
working comedians
yeah and and i won the contest and i had
no idea what i was doing and
i was like i knew 30 seconds into it i'm
like
i'm quitting ibm you know my parents
my mother was like are you on dope uh
what are you what's wrong with you
and five years later i was on johnny
carson the same mother's going you know
you wasted those years that i
[Laughter]
what did you do at ibm jeff well it
sounds more impressive than it was i
carried a tool bag i fixed machines
uh when comp you know if you're
whatever your power source i could bring
a new one and put it in or whatever but
uh that they would have fired me long
long ago
i was not on the fast track there was
anybody else
also part of the great southeastern
laugh-off that i just looked up while we
were giving that answer
anybody else that we would know of are
you the only one to come out of that
that you would know uh i mean there were
some regional people like james gregory
and people like that they're
really funny but uh but
yeah i might be the only one you know
okay very good
and it's all it's clearly all all worked
out
jeff i mean who's who's the funniest
comedian or comedian you've ever come
across
that makes you laugh who is that person
for you
just naturally funny ron white ron white
could recap his day and you would be
beating the table
uh when we did the first blue collar
movie i i think that's the thing you
know
we're all on stools at the end and
telling stories
we were sitting one night at uh like a
denny's or something it's like midnight
we're
we're grabbing late breakfast with and
ron started
hey did i ever tell you about the time i
got
thrown out of a bar in new york city and
and by the time he's finished telling us
i'm going before i'm like dude you've
got
to tell this on stage right and uh so
yeah he's just one of those guys
he could you know tell you what he had
for breakfast and you'd be laughing he's
just
that funny so then what was your biggest
break that got you on carson just they
they saw you doing stand-up and they
they just put you on
on the tonight show that's that was it
you know leno leno was very
very helpful to back back in the days
when jay was like the
king of the road comics right jay had
seen me work down at the comedy magic
club uh in hermosa beach california and
he went back and told johnny about me
uh but i was living in atlanta i was
just on the road right all over the
country
and and my wife said you're never gonna
know if
if you can make it in this if we don't
go to l.a we moved to l.a and
i think we've been there two weeks and i
was doing a set at the improv
and it did the set and i was walking out
to the lobby and jim mccauley the talent
director for carson followed me out in
the lobby and he said
how come you haven't been on carson i
said because you won't open my tapes
i've been mailing you tapes
for two years right and and
and i was on and you know a couple of
weeks later and i'm like hell i'm not
any funnier than i was
three months so long it's just
it's just like it's just like that movie
hoosiers jeff it's just you measure
the rim to the floor and the the front
the the the free throw line to the
baseline it's just the same comedy it's
just a different
you know field house that you're in it
just happens to be the biggest field
house in the history of comedy the
tonight show with johnny carson
yeah right and and back then that was it
uh and out of everything i've ever done
in my career if you said
what's the highlight it would be making
johnny laugh and getting called over
you know to sit and sit on the couch
there that was
that was the mount everest for a
stand-up comedian back then and it was
totally career changing i mean within a
week
i was getting offers to headline vegas
because johnny had called me
to the couch that's it seriously because
he doesn't he didn't he didn't
you know if you made him laugh uh again
i i've read about this i'm just such an
aficionado i did stand-up comedy in
college
for a couple years jeff yes and you like
it i loved it
nothing like making a room laughing uh
making a room laugh and i've also
never done anything tougher literally
has made everything else i've ever done
in my career live
that much easier nothing tougher than
reading a room
and trying to make people laugh and i
did it you know in a student union
and the campus at university of michigan
so it was jammed with all my friends and
packed
the toughest thing i ever did was i went
on the road a couple weekends and did it
in front of 10 people and i
sucked at that and i just didn't know if
i was cut out for it but
nothing is equivalent to that
nothing see i i would think what you do
because there's so much prep that goes
into what you do now
and and it changes every day i i would
think that would be tougher
i mean i look at what you do and go holy
hill how does somebody do that yesterday
today
well i just have so i just for some
reason have retention of the most
useless facts of all time i don't know
why
that's just and it's something that i'm
i'm able to do but
just in terms of again reading a room
trying to make
uh keep fresh material and then when i
do a show like this
if i crack wise and if my audio
executive as he likes to call it
and my mass hole across the way producer
doesn't last
like they are right now i think it's
totally falling flat like if i don't get
the immed
if i don't get the immediate reaction
and it's not their job to laugh at my
stuff but i just if i don't get the
immediate reaction i feel like i have
totally crapped out that's what stand-up
comedy has left for me
pretty much when it's great there's
nothing better but when it's bad there
may not be anything
worse but being called over but being
called over jeff by
johnny that's gotta that you had to be
through the moon when that day happened
you know yeah you know what funny rich
is like if you go through my house i
don't have
stuff all over the walls you know right
but i do have a
uh an 8x10 black and white picture of
sitting in the chair talking to johnny
and johnny's got his mouth wide open
just
gut laughing and and and and i
tell i said that's all i ever wanted to
do i made the you know from when i grew
up you had three channels that was
for a stand-up comic that was it
you know there was no specials there
were no
that was it and uh to make that man
laugh
i remember going home that night and
laying the bed stairs to the ceiling
i i don't have a plan that was it you
know i have no i have no plan
that's like that's like thanks everybody
thanks for coming tip your waitress and
that's the end of the set
right there the career set uh jeff
foxworthy here on the rich island show
do you have any sports memorabilia again
you grew up in atlanta i don't know if
you're an atlanta sports fan if you have
anybody from
you know childhood that you've held on
to anything like that jeff
you know what i actually have and it's
and uh
because i'm doing this new show and now
you need to work for people you know
collect stuff and all
i have i was a huge baseball fan i was
there in 69
the night the braves uh won the division
for the first time and went on to play
the amazing mets and lost them
but so i have autographed baseballs
and and it started with ball players but
then it was like all right if i'm
hosting an award show i
always had baseballs in my backpack if i
did the tonight show or letterman or
whatever base
i may have the most eclectic autographed
baseball collection
like i have a whole section of just
comedians and i've got
johnny carson letterman red skelton
carol burnett don rickles milton berle
richard pryor get out you know when
they're all on baseball
jeff all on baseballs i've got five
presidents on baseballs
i've got tiger woods on a baseball i
you know richard petty dale earnhardt
it's just very eclectic elton john
bob seeger you know all right so
i'll ask you the question of your show
not eastern on a e
what what's it worth jeff have you
figured that out you know what
you know what's funny so so when we're
we're because you gotta
i'm filming the show down in my basement
and so
one one night we're doing it and one of
the appraisers goes what's that baseball
back on the shelf and i
got up and walked back there and one
night when the braves were in the
playoffs back in the 90s i threw out the
first pitch
and you know you shake hands with the
catcher and they flip you the ball and
the guy said hey stand over here they're
going to do the national anthem then
we'll take you back to your seat
so as i'm standing there on the field on
the front row i look over and
president jimmy carter is seated right
there on the front
row and i and i'm holding the baseball
and i look over i said mr president
would you sign this
this is his great first pitch jimmy
carter
and uh so i went back and got it on the
shelf and
and i'm like and and the appraiser
starts asking me questions about what
the ball was worth
3500 bucks get out of here and but
but to me and i learned during the show
i said well there's two values
there's what's it worth to somebody else
yes and they're
what's it worth to you of course and i'm
like well no that was just a cool moment
i wouldn't
you know i mean i guess i would if i was
starving but i wouldn't sell it you know
so
uh yeah so to me almost every one of
them
i got in person and so
it it's like a little snapshot of that
moment
i know i hear you jeff but if to say
that this is personally authenticated by
jeff
foxworthy to get a baseball as a
collection of
people that you've just named i know
it's priceless to you it's got to be
close to priceless in terms of just
reality right i mean that's
i don't imagine there's a lot of johnny
carson autographed baseballs out there
like where
i don't know i don't know like maybe if
somebody sat behind him at dodger
stadium and they caught like a liner off
the bat of you know
steve yeager or something you know right
you know what i mean like
yeager boy that's a good one i'm trying
to time it you know i'm trying to time
it properly
[Laughter]
you know or or buckner to go you know
dodgers obviously uh from back in the
day with uh one of the most famous home
runs of all time is uh henry aaron hit
that was buckner trying to climb the
fence to bring the fame henry aaron uh
baseball back
at the old atlanta falcon county stadium
and and who gave up the
remember who gave it up al dowling
look at us talking ball like this jeff
foxworthy i loved
ball yeah felix mion you still love me
on as a second base oh yeah
i think he choked up on the bat holding
it by the trademark that's how much
he was never going to hit a double you
know so it's like let me get my little
single and i'll be happy
i remember her man oh my gosh jeff
foxworthy here on the rich eisen show so
what what have you seen
through your show where you couldn't
believe that uh that you were able to
appraise
this bauble that's uh on what's what's
it worth on a
e which one jumps out at you jeff there
was a couple of them there was
there was one couple the guy's mom had
given him a drawing
and she told him it was valuable and
his the thing was ugly it was like a
clown and
his wife wouldn't even let him put it up
wouldn't let him hang it in the bathroom
she thought it was so ugly so
i'm talking to them and they get through
the house and he pulls it out from under
the bed i guess that was the hiding
place
ends up the thing's a picasso come on
had somebody else that had when he was
in
he was there and i want to say he was in
michigan and it may have been u of m
okay but he uh andy warhol
came and spoke to their art class
and had was showing them the his
technique for screen printing and he had
ink on his hands
so as he's as he's doing a screen print
he
puts has both of his full hand prints
down next to the thing that he's printed
anyway this thing ends up being worth
half a million
bucks no way can you imagine
it what's kind of fun about this show is
everybody you you you know everybody
has that thing when you're going through
your closet or your drawers that thing
you never throw out because you go
yeah man that might be worth something
um
almost every time somebody thought it
was going to be worth a lot it wasn't
it was the things that people were
almost about to put in a yard sale
that were the things that were worth 50
grand or
80 grand or whatever yeah i mean that's
like
you know that's like the uh the sports
equivalent is like
drafting patrick mahomes like you don't
know what you got but then it turns out
to be a picasso you know and it's worth
it it's priceless that's what everybody
hopes that's what everybody hopes for
that's why it shows like
what's it worth it's so much fun to
watch like uh you never know what's
gonna happen
well that and and and we're doing it
virtually so you're going into
somebody's home they're filming
themselves
with their with their cell phone yeah
and you know rich i used to always
encourage people to go to the fair once
a year if for no other reason
then it made you feel better about your
own family
you know because everybody thinks their
family's nuts
and you get to the fair and you start
looking around you're like hell we're
all right
we're we're damn near royalty look at
these people
and and so that was kind of like what it
was like when people are filming
you know going through the house
it was like hell i thought my house was
dirty we're okay we're good
you're ahead of the game oh man this is
a fun chat jeff i really appreciate you
calling i hope that's the first of many
times at fox outdoors on twitter at
uh real jeff foxworthy on instagram and
thank you for
you know congrats on what's it worth and
let's let's chat some more
let's chat some more oh i would love to
i've enjoyed you for so long this was
fun thanks jeff right back at you right
back at you that's jeff foxworthy that
was a blast of a chat
chat